Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Weißt du was Toadbag heißt?
Wahrscheinlich Jutebeutel. Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 455 von was haben wir
denn heute? 2. März 2023.
Ich habe heute Datum hingeschrieben.
2 3 2 3.
Hätte ich was aufgetan?
2 3 2 3. Oh yeah.
Ja und meines Freundes.
Good point. Ja, wenn unsere Sendungsnummer schon nichts hergeben,
dann muss man sich an so etwas festhalten.
Aber das war ein schöner Moment.
Das hat man nicht so oft, diese besonderen Momente. Ansonsten hätten wir ja
auch jemanden heiraten können jetzt wieder. Naja, verpasst.
Also demnächst haben wir es am 2. 04.24. Also ein Jahr und ein Monat.
Zweiter, Vierter, 24, okay.
Aber das ist halt, also Vorsicht, vier ist keine Primzahl.
Aber könnte sein, dass wir dann ungefähr so die 500. Sendung zusammen haben.
Mal gucken. 500 ist aber auch keine Primzahl.
Toad, Toad heißt übrigens so viel wie to carry or to transport.
Aber jetzt T-O-T-E geschrieben, nicht wie der Toe.
T-O-T-E, genau. Und die Ethymologie ist etwas unklar. Es könnte was mit dem
deutschen Wort Tüte zu tun haben.
Tüte-Bag. Tütesack. Tütesack. Da wir das ja letzte Woche schon angekündigt hatten
und jetzt auch da Vollzug melden können, ist das jetzt natürlich voll das Thema.
Jetzt gibt es auch den Buch, Netzpolitik. Einhornstandarte. Toadbag.
Klingt irgendwie geil. Heißt aber eigentlich Tütensack.
Also der Einhornstandarte Tütensack ist jetzt am Start.
Könnt ihr ordentlich was eintüten oder einsacken, je nachdem. geht beides dann.
Unglaublich. Wir haben natürlich auch dazu ein Feedback bekommen.
Soll ich zum Feedback kommen? Oder möchtest du noch ein bisschen von unserem...
Da gibt es ja nicht so viel darüber zu erzählen. Also, das existiert jetzt einfach
und gibt euch die Möglichkeit euren Supermarkt-Einkauf auch als Werbeträger abzuleisten.
Im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Also nie habt ihr die Werbung so sehr getragen wie dann. Wahnsinn, ne?
Ich überlege gerade was. The Logbook Net Politics Unicorn Ancient.
Tja, was heißt Standard?
Toadbag, ancient. Also das archaische. Ich habe jetzt hier geguckt.
Ich gucke ja ganz einfach auf so ein Standard-Internet-Ding.
Ich habe das jetzt gar nicht. Aber wir können ja mal... Was sagt denn Diepel? So was.
Logbuch Netzpolitik ein Hornstandarte.
Jute Beu... das ist der Logbuch net politics unicorn standard jute back aber ist ja toad back man.
Tja das ist halt nicht jute.
Naa nicht spoilern. Also Logbuch net politics unicorn standard toad back.
Kann du jetzt kaufen im Internet.
Das klang so beeindruckend, ich setzte den Preis gleich mal hoch. Was kostet ihr denn?
Hab ich gar nicht geguckt, was kostet ihr denn?
Schlappe 15 Euro. Das ist natürlich eine verkappte Spende, ne?
An den Bollhersteller oder was?
Was an uns.
Das ist eine schwarze tote bug hier geht es nur um
spenden aus 100 prozent baumwolle
Wir empfehlen dem klimazuliebe kalt
waschen auf der leine trocknen vor dem waschen
auf links drehen Kann ich einfach so in die ecke knöllen und ab und zu mal rausholen
oder so das das ist schon eigentlich mehr auch so für den sonntagsspaziergang
auch dann sehen und gesehen werden. Da läuft man durch den Park mit.
Für gut ist das. Peter hat uns zum Thema Toadbags aufgeklärt.
Kurze Korrektur zu Jute Beuteln. Ihr redet von Beuteln aus Jute,
meint aber allerhöchstwahrscheinlich. Also nicht nur höchstwahrscheinlich,
allerhöchstwahrscheinlich.
Klar, jetzt ein bisschen Materialkunde, es gibt auch Beutel aus Jute.
Die sind braun, kratzig und haben netzartigen Stoff, aber das was man an der
Supermarktkasse kaufen kann oder oft als Werbegeschenk bei einer Messe bekommt,
sind in aller Regel Beutel aus Baumwolle.
Linus kriegt am Ende noch die Kurve und nennt sie korrekt, als er von der Studie
erzählt, welche Klimaverträglichkeit untersucht nennt.
Linus kriegt am Ende noch die Kurve und nennt sie korrekt. Als er von der Studie
erzählt, welche die Klimaverträglichkeit untersucht nennt.
Im Übrigen gebe ich Linus recht, dass solche Beutel eher unnötig sind.
Ah shit sorry, das wollte ich gar nicht mehr vorlesen.
Es ist Blasphemie. Ne, ah geht weiter, geht weiter. Vor allem,
da meiner Meinung nach jeder mehr als genug davor zu Hause hat.
Beutel aus schwarzem Baumstoff hingegen finde ich schon wieder interessanter.
Spoiler.
Weil sie nicht so schnell schmuddelig werden wie die weißen.
Fun Fact, es gibt T aus Jute, haben wir aber nicht. So, danke für eure tolle
Sendung, mach weiter. So, meine Lieblingsfriedenheit ist übrigens die 11.
So, sehr gut. Danke, Peter. Du hast recht, es handelt sich um ein Bauwollbeutel. und schwarz und.
Aber wenn man Jutebeutel sucht, findet man Baumwollbeutel. Das ist ein Klass. Also das ist hier...
Ich finde noch nicht mal wirklich ein Jutebeutel.
Mit Jutebeutel, das ist halt so, das ist so ein bisschen so wie Tempotaschentuch, weißte?
Nee, ja nee. Also Jute ist nicht wie ein Tempotaschentuch.
Nein, nicht im Sinne von, dass es sich auf eine Firma bezieht.
Aber es ist einfach ein Begriff, der dann halt irgendwann gekommen ist,
weil vorher einfach überhaupt niemand mit solchen Beuteln durch die Gegend gelaufen
ist. Dann gab es Jutebeutel und damit ist das sozusagen so ein bisschen der
Begriff für Beutel geworden.
Also wir machen, wir werden jetzt, ich möchte Tim, ich möchte,
dass wir auch einen Jutebeutel anbieten.
Gibt's hier auch? Gibt's. Und dann sagen wir aber, das ist ein Potato Bag.
Was?
Potato Bag. Nee, so kennst du den hässlichen alten Kartoffelsack?
Ja, der ist bestimmt aus Jute, oder? Ja. Bäh.
Bäh. Gut, dass es bei uns, also wenn ihr überlegt, was das YouTube wollte,
hier bei uns gibt's einen richtig schönen Toadbag.
In schwarz. In schwarz. Zum rumtragen.
Tütensack. Gut, danke Peter.
So, dann haben wir Jan und Peter. Moment. Und Peter?
Moment, wieso hat der Peter keine? Nee, nur ein Kommentar, Peter. Jetzt ein bisschen...
Kommst du ins Schleudern jetzt ein bisschen?
Ich weiß nicht, ob es ein anderer Peter ist, aber der hat gesagt, zur Kabelthematik.
Also Thema, wir haben ja darüber gesprochen, dass ein Bagger ein Kabel durchgebaggert
hat und dann die Lufthansa am Boden bleiben musste, weil keiner mehr einchecken konnte.
Konnte. Und dazu sagt Peter, zur Kabelthematik ist es leider so,
dass selbst die Kabelbetreiber meist nicht genau wissen, wo ihr Kabel verläuft.
Bei Bauarbeiten im Bereich von Bahnen stößt man oft auf Kabelquerungen,
die schlecht bis gar nicht dokumentiert sind.
So trennt man dann Kabel, die so weit vom Plan entfernt sind,
dass man die Suchschachtungen schon längst aufgegeben hat. Also die sagen,
hier muss irgendwo ein Kabel, also irgendwo haben die ein Kabel eingezeigt, ist aber gar nicht da.
Und weiterhin kommentiert der Kommentar war jetzt aber glaube ich dann von Jan.
Peter, wenn das der gleiche Peter war, dann jeder nur ein Kommentar.
So und Jan sagt, hallo, Dino-Side-Tim, der Glasfaser-Vorfall in Frankfurt war
in jüngster Zeit nicht das einzige Malheur.
Bereits wenige Tage vorher, am 10.2., hat ebenfalls bei Bauarbeiten ein Bagger
in Düsseldorf gleich 17 Glasfaserkabel erwischt und damit den Dienstleister
IT NRW für sechs Stunden offline genommen.
Davon betroffen waren Notrufe und die Inhalt auf Dritte nahezu sämtlicher Landesministerien
und nachgestellten Behörden.
Mir scheint, dass die entsprechende Dokumentation von verlegten Leitungen generell
ein größeres Problem ist. Beide Stimmen, bei der Peter und Jan haben recht.
Die sieht man halt auch nicht unter ihr Schnött. Das ist wahrscheinlich das
Problem. Und dann hat mir stabil fragil auf Mastodon in einem Tooth,
in einem Tooth mit Tooth.
Nicht Tooth, also gezeigt, weil ich ja gesagt habe, wie kriegt man so ein riesen
Kabel mit so vielen Fasern irgendwie hin?
Und da gibt es jetzt ein Bild, das habe ich aber auch nicht verstanden.
Also das Bild zeigt eine Glasfasermuffe für Kabel mit
192 Fasern im E- und MMS-System, das ist das Einzel- und Mehrfaser-Management-System,
ohne Spleiß als Loopmuffe gebaut.
So, da kann sich jetzt jeder vorstellen, was das zeigt.
Ich konnte es mir nicht vorstellen nach der Bildbeschreibung und ich verstehe
es auch nicht, wenn ich mir das Bild angucke.
Aber das Bild zeigt eine E- und MMS-Muffe, also eine Einzel- und Mehrfaser-Management-Systemmuffe,
ohne Spleiß als Loopmuffe.
Und die Loopmuffe, die verbindet jetzt die 192 Fasern, die jeweils in einem
Bündel sind. Das ist gelb, da sind 12 Fasern drin.
Muss man sich angucken, ist eine Lupe-Mufe.
Also mir ist immer noch nicht ganz klar, wie das funktioniert,
aber so verbindet man das.
Es gibt da auf jeden Fall Techniken, um das schnell durchführen zu können.
Ich habe mich halt eher, wenn die so gerissen sind, wie kriegt man dann die
einzelnen Fasern zugeordnet?
Ja, das wäre jetzt auch mein Problem.
Es ist wahrscheinlich sinnlos, das am Kabel selber zu machen.
Du multiplexes einfach auf der anderen Seite. Das heißt, wichtig ist,
dass nur Fasern verbunden sind. Und wenn die dann miteinander verbunden sind,
dann kann ja sozusagen auf beiden Seiten ein bisschen Software sagen und okay,
okay, das ist jetzt hier, das kommt jetzt hier an, das kommt jetzt da an.
Und dann wird es sozusagen automatisch zugeordnet, weil sonst wirst du da bekloppt
bei. Du musst ja jedes Mal wieder aufbuddeln.
Mit AI.
Das ist kein AI, das ist einfach...
Was wir alles mit AI machen.
Ja, ja, AI. Da brauchst du ganz normale AI.
Tim, wenn du mir von deinem Code, den du da jetzt gerade in Elixier schreibst,
redest, dann habe ich auch den Eindruck, dass der bald Bewusstsein entwickelt,
so wie du davon schwärzt.
Das stimmt, das stimmt. Da bin ich schon nah dran.
Also es gibt eine Loopmuffe und ja, ich sag mal...
Ich bin ganz froh, dass ich das nicht bedienen muss.
Aber ja, es wird ja irgendwie gehen. Spannende Loopmuffe. Aber du hast recht,
wahrscheinlich bleibst du da einfach alles aneinander.
Hauptsache einer am anderen. Und dann kannst du reinleuchten und guckst einfach, wer ist wo verbunden.
Und dann sagst du, das war der jetzt.
Sowieso dahin fertig.
Wenn die alle zur selben anderen Seite zeigen. Sonst ist schlecht.
Ja, sonst ist es ein bisschen schwierig. Aber dann müssen sie ja zwangsläufig.
Du machst ja nicht die Hälfte des Kabels dann auf und dann geht das nochmal
20 Kilometer in eine andere Richtung.
Also auf jeden Fall. Da wird wahrscheinlich dann ein Switch stehen.
Okay, ich glaube, wir haben jetzt genug Quatsch geredet, dass das in den nächsten
Kommentaren alles richtig gestellt und uns erklärt wird.
Denn wir wissen ja, wenn du vom Internet eine Antwort haben möchtest auf eine
Frage, dann Ich stelle nicht die Frage, sondern gebe eine falsche Antwort.
Und das haben wir hiermit getan.
Falsche Antwort hat ja auch Bing in einem Screenshot, den ich noch nicht mal
weiß, ob der echt war, gegeben.
Und zwar, dass der Mars von der Mars Congressional Republic bewohnt wäre und
dort eine Bevölkerung von 10 Milliarden sitzt.
Dazu kommentiert, nicht kommentiert, das ist erklärt, erklärt der Matzekult.
Eine mögliche Erklärung für die Geschichte mit dem Mars, ohne jetzt den besagten
Screenshot gesehen zu haben von den Liebessprachen, möglicherweise stammen die
Informationen aus der Buch- und TV-Serie The Expanse.
Denn dort heißt die Regierung des Mars Marsion Congressional Republic Und der
Mars hat eine Bevölkerung von rund 10 Milliarden.
Allerdings unterscheidet sich diese Zahl zwischen Buch- und TV-Serie.
Und diese Information ist zu finden im Expans Fandom Wiki.
So, ja, klingt naheliegend, würde ich sagen.
Bin ich überzeugt, weil der Satz war auch einfach 100% genau der.
Also, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Überzeugendes Fandom Wiki. Wir mussten ja die Zahl der Bevölkerung von Mars
nach unten korrigieren. Ich warte ja, weißt du worauf? Ich warte,
Tim, dass der Elon Musk zu Mars fliegt und sich da festklebt.
Ich finde das mit diesem Fest... Da wäre ich sehr für zu haben, ja.
Das wird hier festklebt. Das könnte viel mehr kulturelle Aneignungen erfahren.
Das ist bestimmt nicht erlaubt.
So, Chatkontrolle.
Ist noch nicht vorbei. Ja, ist nicht vorbei, bleibt. Aber es gab einen neuen
Höhepunkt der netzpolitischen Geschichte. Und ich muss sagen,
ich glaube, das ist das erste Mal, dass es einen solchen Höhepunkt gab. Da kommen wir gleich zu.
Also zunächst einmal hat das BMI ein neues Positionspapier veröffentlicht.
Netzpolitik Org Andre Meister hat es dort ein bisschen auseinandergenommen, hat das alles erklärt.
Sie wollen jetzt irgendwie Server-seitig scannen, also Client-Site-Scanning.
Das scanning auf dem endgerät würden sie gerne ausschließen.
Also, dass dieses Scannengeschichte auf eurem Telefon selber stattfinden soll
und somit Verschlüsselung umgeht, ja, davon haben sie Abstand genommen.
Und jetzt gibt es natürlich einen Punkt, weil das war der übelste Teil dieser Verordnung.
Jetzt könnte man sagen, ah wunderbar, wir haben dafür gesorgt,
dass das Innenministerium dagegen ist und damit ist jetzt die Chatkontrolle besiegt.
Also der Teil, der richtig kritische Teil dieser Verordnung,
von dem hat sich jetzt zumindest die Bundesregierung abgewendet.
Dem vorangegangen waren, das FDP hatte ja rote Linien, da hat das BMI,
das Bundesministerium fürs Innere, im Dezember ein Positionspapier rausgegeben,
das hat im Prinzip einfach mal alle roten Linien der FDP eingesammelt.
Dann gab es ein Gespräch zwischen Nancy Faser, Marco Buschmann,
Volker Wissing und Familienministerin Lisa Paus.
Also geballte Kompetenz am Tisch und
haben sich jetzt auf diese neuen Teil geeinigt. Sowas bleibt aber drin.
Beziehungsweise wo sind sie sich noch ich so einig, serverseitiges Scan von
Chats und Clouds. Also wenn deine persönliche Kommunikation nicht verschlüsselt
ist, dann soll sie weiterhin in einem Scan unterliegen.
Und quasi dann serverseitig, also auf dem E-Mail-Server, auf dem Server von
WhatsApp, auf dem Server von wer auch immer unverschlüsselte Nachrichten transportiert.
Frag man sich natürlich...
Also schon heute findet das ja nicht statt, dass solche Chats genutzt werden
von Menschen, die dokumentierten Kindesmissbrauch massenhaft verbreiten.
Zumindest nicht in großer Menge. Jetzt wäre die Frage,
für wen glaubst du jetzt noch diesen Aufwand zu betreiben,
wenn du sagst, wir monitorieren jetzt unverschlüsselte Chats mit einer in einer
EU-weiten Verordnung geregelten Maßnahme und erwarten, dass wir da noch irgendwas finden.
Das ist also ein bisschen schwach.
Gleichzeitig auf Servern, also in Clouds wissen wir, wir haben es hier ja auch
öfter diskutiert, wird gescannt.
Also wenn du jetzt in eine unverschlüsselte Cloud Daten legst,
zum Beispiel bei Microsoft, Google, Apple, ne Apple nicht,
Entschuldigung, das war Microsoft, Google, Amazon oder so und sich eine Datei
befindet, die in der NECMAC-Datenbank ist, dann wird das nicht lange dauern,
bis diese Datei gelöscht ist und dein Account gesperrt wird.
Wir erinnern uns an viele Berichte zu diesem Thema,
inklusive dem Bericht, dass es da eben auch offenbar bei Google schon so eine Art AI gibt,
die also jetzt nicht nur NECMAC, sondern eben auch Bilder Kontext zu erkennen,
die dazu geführt hat, dass dieser Mann, der ein Foto von seinem Kind an einen
Arzt geschickt hat, sein Google-Account verloren hat.
Gleichzeitig ist es insbesondere schlecht, weil ja Cloud-Speicher de facto,
wenn man sich jetzt mal insbesondere in den letzten paar Jahren die Entwicklung anschaut,
dein Zuhause werden. Also schauen wir uns an, wie ein Unternehmen heutzutage funktioniert.
Die arbeiten dann mit Microsoft 365, was im Prinzip diese Kollaborationsfunktionen
in Microsoft Word reinholt.
Alle Dateien werden über OneDrive zugegriffen.
Deine Foto-Library vom iPhone ist in der Apple Cloud oder vom Android in der Google Cloud.
Deine Dokumente sind dort diese Unternehmen entwickeln sich ja dahin,
dass so etwas wie ich habe Speicher auf meinem Gerät in zunehmendem Maße an Bedeutung verliert.
Bevor das jetzt wieder sehr viele kommentieren, dass sie da nicht mitmachen, ja, das ist super schön.
Aber für die Entwicklung, wie sich ja, wie sich die Gesellschaft,
wie sich die Unternehmen, sich die Kultur und Wirtschaft der Welt entwickelt,
ist das am Ende immer relativ unerheblich, ob wir mitmachen oder nicht.
Das ist dann schon relativ weit verbreitet in dieser Form.
Umso erstaunlicher, wenn diese Scans ohnehin schon stattfinden,
warum soll das dann diese Chat-Kontrolle-Geschichte?
Also da scheint ja dann auch wiederum kein Regelungsbedarf zu bestehen.
Na gut, ich meine, das ist ja alles so, dass sie sehen ja die unverschlüsselten
Server langsam schwinden.
Ja, ja, aber das, aber sie sagen hier ja spezifisch unverschlüsselt.
Also sie sagen, verschlüsselten Teil nicht, unverschlüsselten machen wir Scanning.
Serverseitiges Scannen von unverschlüsselten Inhalten.
Klar, aber die gehen halt weg, die unverschlüsselten Server.
Richtig, umso erstaunlicher, dass sie jetzt sagen, da müssen wir unbedingt noch scannen. Das geht.
Ja, stand schon drin. Ich meine, das ist ja das aktuelle Gesetz auch in den USA schon.
Die haben das ja zu tun, die Firmen machen das ja nicht.
Richtig, also man fragt sich ernsthaft, wo der Regulierungsbedarf ist,
wo die Zukunftsperspektive ist.
Das ist relativ dumm, da jetzt noch sich noch mit zu befassen.
Okay, dann natürlich auch, also hier ist die FDP wieder drin,
dass sie sagen, da soll nämlich auf diesen unverschlüsselten Cloud-Dingern,
wenn ich das hier richtig verstehe, soll, gibt es noch nicht eine Antwort,
ob sie nur mit bekannten Missbrauchsmaterial, also ne, sag mal FileHash und
wenn er in der NekMek-Datenbank ist, tu etwas.
Und das wäre im Zweifelsfall ohnehin sehr einfach, weil die Datei,
die da hochliegt, wird ohnehin gehashed. Unter anderem einfach für die Integritätssicherung.
Ja, also das ist relativ simpel. Wer da mal ganz kurz so ein Nek-Mek hash und fertig.
Ob da jetzt aber auch bislang unbekannte Missbrauchsdarstellungen und Grooming
gesucht werden soll, ist noch nicht ganz klar.
Da wird also noch weiter diskutiert. Auf jeden Fall keine sinnvolle Idee.
Und die FDP-Ministerien fordern auch diesen Aspekt unbekanntes Material und Grooming.
Das Innenministerium will es beibehalten. So.
Gut, jetzt zanken die sich also erstmal nur noch über Inhalte auf der...
Also unverschlüsselte Inhalte in der Cloud, das sind dann am Ende doch mehr
als du meinst, insbesondere iPhone-Backups von vielen Millionen Menschen und so weiter.
Also es ist noch eine ganze Menge, die da gescannt werden soll.
Aber sagen wir mal so, man könnte jetzt sagen, da geht es auf jeden Fall mehr
in die richtige Richtung.
Ein paar wichtige Schritte müssen noch gemacht werden und vor allem das,
was jetzt noch übrig ist, da könnte man ernsthaft mal den Regulierungsbedarf
in Frage stellen, weil das eben schon gängige Praxis ist.
Was aber ein großes Problem ist, und da erinnere ich mich als Viktor und Khaleesi
zum ersten Mal hier in der Sendung, wann das wir schon sagten,
hier, Altersverifikation.
Und es gibt nun mal keine sinnvolle, belastbare Möglichkeit,
eine Altersverifikation durchzuführen, die nicht am Ende an deinem Personalausweis gebunden ist.
Jetzt kann ich natürlich ein Ist-18-Zertifikat ausstellen.
Also das ist ja ohne Zweifel möglich
und das ist auch für bestimmte Anwendungszwecke potentiell denkbar.
Dass man beispielsweise in einem neuen Personalausweis oder in so neuer ist
der ja gar nicht mehr sagt,
der kriegt so ein Flag, wo signiert ist, die Person, die diesen Ausweis hat,
die auf diesem Ausweis abgebildet ist, die ist über 18 und dann kann man digital
nur auslesen, so sinngemäß True-False.
Also du fragst den Ausweis, ist die Person 18 und dann sagt der Ausweis ja, nein.
Und die Antwort ist quasi signiert mit einem Echtzeitzertifikat,
dass nur dieser Ausweis sagen konnte und von mir aus auch, dass du einen PIN dazu eingegeben hast.
Stellen wir uns das vor. Dann könntest du also einen verbrieften Nachweis führen,
der beweist oder der dir attestiert, dass du 18 bist und dem Kontrollierenden
aber nicht in digitaler Form sagt, wie du heißt, wo du wohnst,
wann du überhaupt geboren bist, dass du in Wirklichkeit schon 19 bist und solche Dinge.
Aber ein solcher Nachweis in digitaler Form ist ja wertlos, wenn nicht gleichzeitig
kontrolliert wird, wer ihn gerade erbringt.
Sonst würdest du ja einfach dir einmal attestieren lassen, dass du über 18 bist
und ich könnte mit deinem IS 18 Nachweis auf irgendeine Plattform gehen und sagen, ich bin 18.
Oder noch viel schlimmer, wenn es eine Kinderplattform ist, könnte jetzt irgendwie
ein erwachsener Mensch mit dem
Altersnachweis eines Kindes sich dort einschleichen unter falschem Alter.
Also ein richtig fester, prüfbarer Altersnachweis muss am Ende irgendwo an deine
Identität gekoppelt sein,
weil ja sichergestellt werden muss, dass dieser Nachweis auch dir spezifisch
persönlich ausgestellt wurde.
Insbesondere, wenn man eine Motivation unterstellt, dass du potenziell über dein Alter lügst, Tim.
Das würde ich niemals tun.
Das würdest du niemals tun. Du interessierst dich aber auch nur im Internet für Sachen ab 18.
Na ja, gut, also.
So, noch dazu, ja, also es ist nicht möglich, den Nachweis, dass man ein gewisses
Alter hat, zu führen, ohne auch nachzuweisen, dass man selber die Person ist,
der dieser Nachweis ausgestellt wurde.
Und dass es ist, also sorry, es funktioniert einfach nicht.
Ja, allein der Institution gegenüber, die dir diesen Nachweis ausstellt,
musst du dir deine Identität nachweisen. Da muss dir quasi wer auch immer diese
Nachweisprüfung macht, muss das wiederum von anderen prüfen lassen. Ist das echt?
Also jetzt können sehr gerne ein paar theoretische Informatiker kommen und mir
nochmal zeigen, wie man das mit Zero-Knowledge-Proof und so weiter hinkriegt.
Und dann würde ich einfach nur auf Nancy Feser und Ilva Johansson zeigen und
sagen, glaubste, so wird es am Ende sein.
Es ist wirklich nicht sinnvoll möglich.
Und das Problem mit dieser ganzen Altersverifikation ist ja,
wir alle würden daran gewöhnt, die ganze Zeit diesen Nachweis zu zeigen,
der eben gezwungenermaßen, selbst mit irgendeinem Zero-Knowledge-Proof,
und hast du nicht gesehen, an uns persönlich gebunden sein muss.
Und auch einzigartig sein muss.
Also an uns gebunden. Sonst könnte ja seine Echtheit und seine Einzigartigkeit
nicht mehr nachgewiesen werden.
Also das ist alles nichts, das führt zu nichts und deswegen ist das jetzt die
große Gefahr im Fahrwasser dieser Chatkontrolle,
jetzt schließe ich der Kreis, wie es Viktor und Khaleesi schon in der ersten,
jetzt sage ich schon Anhörung, im ersten Podcast bei uns, wo sie im ersten Besuch
bei uns in der Sendung gesagt haben, da ist noch ein riesiges Problem und das
schwimmt da gerade im Fahrwasser der Chatkontrolle.
Konzentriert sich auf die Chat-Kontrolle, aber wir müssen auch dieses Thema bekämpfen.
Sodass jetzt selbst mit dem, was jetzt da mit FDP und Nancy Faeser und Hass
und nicht gesehen zusammengeschrieben wurde und Lisa Paus von den Grünen,
auch das ist noch abzulehnen.
Das ist immer noch ein schlimmer Teil der Chat-Kontrolle und sogenannten CSA-Verordnung.
Und deswegen gab es dazu diese Woche am Mittwoch, heute ist Donnerstag,
eine Anhörung im Digitalausschuss.
Digitalausschuss, ich glaube immer noch nicht federführend, also im Prinzip
so ein, ja, kann man jemand was sagen, hat jetzt keine unmittelbaren Konsequenzen.
Die haben jetzt mal gesagt, wir machen eine Anhörung zu dieser CSA-Verordnung.
Wir haben viele unterschiedliche Leute eingeladen, interessant.
Und wenn so eine Anhörung stattfindet, ich habe ja hier schon öfter von so einer
Anhörung berichtet, dann darf dieser Ausschuss Sachverständige laden.
Und geladen werden die vom Ausschusssekretariat, aber vorgeschlagen werden die
natürlich von den Parteien,
sodass sich streckenweise so ein bisschen die,
ja auch teilweise die Lesart durchgesetzt hat,
das ist der von der CDU bestellte Sachverständige, das ist die von der Linken
bestellte Sachverständige, das ist die von der Grünen.
Tatsächlich sind die natürlich immer oder hoffentlich immer da als unabhängige Personen, natürlich,
trotzdem.
Sollte man erwarten, dass die Fraktionen in der Lage sind, eine Person zu finden,
die potenziell auch das sagt, was sie selbst politisch vertreten.
So, das wäre so die allgemeine Erwartung. Es wäre jetzt total ungünstig,
zum Beispiel, wenn die CDU sagt, oh, Kinderschutz und so weiter.
Jetzt müssen wir endlich mal hier draufhauen und so weiter. Ja,
lass uns da mal einen Oberstaatsanwalt im Cybercrime-Bereich hinschicken,
der in NRW zum Beispiel das Zentrale Abwehrzentrum Cybercrime leitet und der
Vertritt dann die Position Chatkontrolle
völliger Wahnsinn lassen sein und Vorzeitenspeicherung übrigens auch.
So und so geht unsere Arbeit. Hier könnte uns das erleichtern und so und so nicht.
Oder wenn jetzt jemand auf die Idee käme, den Kinderschutzbund dorthin zu bestellen,
in der Erwartung, dass vielleicht der Kinderschutzbund jetzt sagt,
boah super, wir müssen unbedingt was machen.
Aber selbst der Kinderschutzbund kommt also in diese Anhörung und sagt,
ja ne, also schöne Idee, aber,
Denkt bitte auch an die Kinder und an deren Rechte, die ihr damit natürlich ebenfalls verletzt.
Und so beginnt die Stellungnahme vom Vorsitzenden des Kinderschutzbund Bundesverbandes, EV, Joachim Türck.
In dieser Debatte werden häufig Datenschutz und Kinderschutz gegeneinander ausgespielt.
Ein der Sache nicht gerecht werdende Ansatz. Die Kinderrechte brauchen beides.
Das Recht auf körperliche Unversehrtheit, aber auch das Recht auf geschützte Kommunikation.
Zonk, also der Kinderschutzbund, spricht sich gegen zentrale Überwachungspunkte
in dieser Verordnung aus.
Der Staatsanwalt Markus Hartmann, Oberstaatsanwalt und Leiter der zentralen
Ansprechstelle Cybercrime W.
Warnt vor Hacking-Risiken und autoritären Tendenzen. Es ist daher aus Sicht
der Informationssicherheit von einem gesteigerten Risiko auszugehen,
weil gehackt wird, was gebaut wird.
Hinsichtlich der Signalwirkung für autoritäre Staaten besteht hier eine besondere Sachkunde nicht.
Also Staatsanwalt, dessen Kernarbeit, die Strafverfolgung im digitalen Bereich
ist, spricht sich dagegen aus.
Und natürlich auch Elina Eichstätt. Der Name hat bei einer ganzen Menge Leute
für Verwirrung gesorgt. Wer ist denn Elina Eichstätt?
Unseren Hörerinnen wahrscheinlich eher bekannt als Khaleesi.
Ah, oh was heu, ach die war das, ja genau, die war das.
Die ist als Vertreterin des Chaos Computer Clubs in dieser Anhörung gegangen
und hat da die Positionen vertreten, die sie ja auch hier in der Sendung schon öfter vertreten hat.
Und hat spezifisch nochmal auch auf dieses Thema Ausweispflicht durch die Hintertür hingewiesen.
Die Altersverifikation, die
letztendlich nur durch eine Internet-Ausweispflicht erreicht werden kann.
Damit also die Abschaffung der Anonymität im Internet und eine weltweite Präzedenz,
die selbst in Russland oder China noch undenkbar ist.
Also es ist wirklich irre, diese Eva Johansson, die spielt hier wirklich mit
dem Feuer und ich bin hoffnungsvoll,
dass jetzt irgendwie hier bei Netzpolitik Org getitelt wird,
9 zu 0 gegen die Chatkontrolle, weil es gab nicht einen Sachverständigen,
den die gefunden haben, der sagt, das sollen wir machen.
Und das ist schon, ich würde sagen, einmalig.
Also das ist in einem netzpolitischen Überwachungsinstrument, Diskussionsding.
Die haben sie immer früher noch den BKA-Zirke geholt oder Irgendeiner hat dann schon...
Weißt du, noch irgendeinen hast du schon gefunden, der das Thema dramatisiert hat oder so was.
Aber es ist schon bemerkenswert, wenn das dann nicht stattfindet,
weil wie du ja schon gesagt hast,
also oft ist das eben in diesen Ausschüssen so, also ich will jetzt diesen Ausschüssen
auch nicht unbedingt unterstellen,
dass sie jetzt überhaupt nichts zur Fakten-Realitätsermittlung beitragen wollen,
Aber es ist natürlich schon oft so, dass man dann eben gerne Beiträge auch einsammelt,
die so einen ohnehin schon gefassten Meinungsbeschluss in irgendeiner Form auch mittragen.
Das ist ja auch in gewisser Hinsicht verständlich, dass das gemacht wird,
und das wird auch jeder erwarten.
Ich meine mich auch irgendwann zu erinnern, dass wir das auch schon mal hatten
in irgendeinem anderen Ausschuss. Ausschuss lange lange ist es her.
Ja es gab immer mal was wo alle dagegen waren. Aber weißt du,
Ich glaube beim IT-Sicherheitsgesetz 2.0, da waren jetzt nicht wirklich viele
die Sachen, das war toll.
Aber vielleicht, hier, ich sollte mal noch alle Sachverständigen kurz benennen.
Ich habe jetzt Elina Eichstätt benannt, Markus Hartmann, der leitende Oberstaatsanwalt
an der Zentrale und Ansprechstelle Cybercrime Nordrhein-Westfalen,
Ella Jakubowska, die ist von EDIRI, dort ist die Senior Policy Advisor,
Felix Reeder, ebenfalls gern gesehener Sendungsgast bei uns von der GFF.
Dann Martin Steinebach vom Fraunhofer Institut für sichere Informationstechnologie.
Dort Leiter der Abteilung Media Security und IT Forensics.
Joachim Türk habe ich gerade gesagt, der vom Kinderschutzbund,
Bundesverband als Mitglied des Bundesvorstandes
und stellvertretender Landesvorsitzender dort aufgetreten ist.
Theresa Wiedlock vom Verein für liberale Netzpolitik, Loathev,
wo sie stellvertretende Vorsitzende ist, Professor Ulrich Kälber,
der Bundesbeauftragte für den Datenschutz und Informationsfreiheit und Dr.
Gerhard Scharp-Hüser, Vizepräsident des Bundesamts für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik.
Alle sind dahingegangen und gesagt so Leute, schlechte Idee.
Und das ist schon ja sehr, sehr eindeutig.
Das könnte man, also das, das ist, irgendjemand hätte es gefallen können,
also vielleicht wenigstens die Fraktion, deren Wähler Todesstrafe für Kinder,
Schänder als Heckscheibenaufkleber auf ihrem tiefergelegten Opel Omega 1,6 Liter
mit Sportauspuff haben, wenigstens die hätten doch jemanden finden können.
Aber auch denen ist es nicht gelungen.
Das ist dann schon sehr eindeutig und…,
Da lohnt es sich jetzt vielleicht mal kurz zu reflektieren. Als dieses Thema
auf uns zukam, haben wir uns natürlich sofort Gedanken gemacht,
wie kann man damit umgehen.
Ich weiß noch, als ich dazu bei Markus Lanz war,
irgendwann letztes Jahr, dass ich auch dann von dieser Person von Innocence in Danger,
die jetzt auch nicht unbedingt für einen differenzierten Umgang mit dem Thema bekannt sind,
Saas, da wusste ich schon, wir haben das ja auch immer wieder,
wir haben das mit den Stoppschildern gehabt und man, es gibt vielleicht so ein bisschen Hoffnung,
dass dann irgendwie doch so ein bisschen Ratio sich durchsetzt,
trotz aller Durchzugskraft, die so ein Thema eben verspricht,
für Überwachungsgesetze.
Kann doch nicht sein, dass Kriminelle einfach solche Bilder sich in uns her schicken.
Da muss man die Aufklärungsarbeit leisten und sagen, das tun sie nicht.
Das tun sie auf anderen Wegen und es wäre super, sich um diese Wege zu kümmern,
statt jetzt unter der Laterne zu suchen, wo man nun mal den Schlüssel nicht verloren hat.
Und all sowas. Da wird jetzt ein Jahr lang gearbeitet und die Datenschützer gebäscht und so.
Und es stimmt dann doch ein bisschen positiv, dass es dann eben gelingt,
diese Argumente dann doch vorzutragen.
Und auf eine gewisse Weise, jetzt werde ich hier fast schon pathetisch,
ist uns das dann doch öfter gelungen.
Pathetisch. empathetisch. Fortseitenspeicherung, Netzsperren.
Als ich der Telekom jetzt vorgetragen habe, dass sie, weil sie mir Stream on
gekündigt haben, dass ich jetzt eine Flatrate kriege, hat es mal nicht geklappt.
Aber sonst eigentlich.
Kommt dem, du bist doch so ein Optimist.
Ja und? Was soll ich dazu beitragen?
Ja, sag mal, wir kippen jetzt die Chatkontrolle.
Also, es ist ja so ein bisschen diffus, immer mit diesen ganzen Verhandlungen.
Wir haben das ja nun auch schon oft gesehen, selbst wenn sich da auf den letzten
Metern irgendwas positiv abgezeichnet hat, dass es dann am Ende doch zusammengekracht ist.
Dass noch einer mit dem Arsch einreißt, weil er den falschen Knopf hat.
Ja, weil am Ende da Kräfte walten, die sich dann doch so in einem gefühlten Konsens entziehen.
Das jetzt hier der Fall sein wird, ist natürlich schwer zu sagen.
Aber ich habe zumindest jetzt den Eindruck gewonnen, dass doch erhebliche Zweifel aufkommen daran,
dass das sozusagen so eine Maßnahme ist, die wirklich was bringt und wo dann schnell,
also wo sagen wir mal dieser Druck im Sinne von,
das müssen wir jetzt unbedingt tun, wenn der so nicht da ist,
dann setzen sich dann halt doch schnell solche grundsätzlichen Haltungen durch,
wie zum Beispiel bei der FDP, wenn es um Vorratsdatenspeicherung geht und so weiter.
Da wird schon mal immer so was getriggert, so nach dem Motto,
das können wir so nicht verkaufen.
Das Feigenblatt des Liberalismus muss da justiert werden und von daher kann
ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass das am Ende so weit entschärft wird,
dass es zumindest keine unmittelbaren Konsequenzen hat.
Aber ich werde das jetzt nicht vorher sagen.
Macht nur den Eindruck.
Du hast natürlich recht, die Entschärfung ist es, weil am Ende wollen sie glaube
ich nicht, dass in der Tagesschau gesagt wird und das ist ja das,
was dann doch spätestens in der Tagesschau käme.
Die Europäische Union hat sich entschieden, eine Verordnung zum Schutz der Kinder
im Internet abzulehnen.
Das wollen sie alle nicht.
Also irgendwas muss da jetzt noch durch und da muss man jetzt gucken,
dass man denen irgendetwas gibt.
Also insofern dieses, da, weißt du,
wenn sie jetzt auf unverschlüsselten Inhalten auf Cloud-Servern suchen wollen,
was jetzt ohnehin schon gemacht wird, dann ist das immer noch keine sinnvolle
Maßnahme und immer noch ein Grundrechtseinbruch in potenziell sehr sensible Daten.
Aber dann würde ich jetzt so ein bisschen fatalistisch sagen,
naja, okay, dann tun sie wieder was für die Verschlüsselung.
Schauen wir mal, wie sich das weiterentwickelt. Es ist auch viel zu früh sich zu freuen,
weil nur weil hier irgendwie die Bundesregierung mal Positionspapiere rausbringt,
heißt das ja noch lange nicht, dass sie die auch wirklich mit Vehemenz in den
internationalen und intereuropäischen Diskussionen auch vertreten und daraus
letzten Endes auch die letzte Konsequenz ziehen,
potenziellen Veto oder sowas einzulegen. Also da sind wir noch lange nicht.
Und Einschränkungen in Deutschland sind wir sowieso irgendwie eines der wenigen
Länder, dieses Thema überhaupt mal ein bisschen sinnvoller diskutiert.
Also ja, ist noch lange, ist noch viel zu früh sich zu freuen,
aber war doch mal so ein schöner Moment. Moment, man kann ja mal einen Moment genießen.
So bleiben wir bei der EU-Kommission.
Und ihr guten Ideen.
Das Internet kitzelt die ja schon so ein bisschen. Die haben jetzt gemerkt, das gibt's.
Die Agrarsubventionen haben sie durchreguliert.
Also jetzt müssen sich was Neues. Genau, jetzt müssen neue Subventionen her.
Und da ist ja mal keine Kohle da. Dann haben sie sich was ganz Neues ausgedacht
und gesagt, es wäre es, wenn jetzt die Subventionen, die bezahlen,
einfach aus dem Ausland kommen.
Dann müssten wir das nicht bezahlen. Das ist doch geil, oder?
Das ist, glaube ich, so ein bisschen der Plan.
Also es gibt da einen Bittenmarkt Kommissar. hatte ich auch neulich hier in
der Sendung mit Carliszi auch
schon mal zitiert, dass der gerade von dem großen Internet im All träumt.
Es gibt ja da auch so ein Projekt, die EU-Kommission beauftragt die ESA mit,
wir brauchen jetzt auch irgendwie sowas wie Starlink.
Spoiler, wird nicht kommen, also wird vielleicht irgendwann kommen,
aber auf gar keinen Fall. Also schnell genug sowieso nicht.
Und auch schon gar nicht mit dem, was sie jetzt angekündigt haben.
Wo es schon so Webseiten gibt mit ersten Services nächstes Jahr und so weiter.
Also von so einem Starlink-like-Internettdienst ist das ganz weit entfernt.
Und auch ansonsten scheint Europa, wie sie das wahrscheinlich in Deutschland
gelernt haben, noch ein bisschen weit weg zu sein. Auf jeden Fall Thierry Breton.
Den gibt es ja schon ein bisschen länger auch so auf der Bühne,
der großen Bühne, Weil der war ja mal, bevor er Binnenmarktkommissar war,
war er mal Chef der France Telekom.
Von 2002 bis 2005. Also nur ein paar Jährchen, jetzt nicht so lange.
Aber da hat er so ein bisschen seine Hut.
Was hat er das hier erzählt? Das ist der, der jetzt in deren Interesse da oben weitermacht.
Kann man jetzt mal unterstellen oder auch nicht, ist ja auch erstmal egal.
Auf jeden Fall derzeit treibt er entsprechende Pläne voran, so eine Art Breitbandsteuer einzuführen.
Heißen tut das gigabit infrastructure act
und ist halt generell beseelt von
der problematik dass wir ja wie wir alle wissen so mit dem breitbandausbau da
geht noch was so in europa so generell uns ja so teuer und was hören wir die
telekom nicht auch schon lange klagen wie teuer das alles ist Also Glasfaser,
Plastik da drin.
Du brauchst halt eine ganze Menge Loopmuffen.
Wenn der Bagger kommt, da muss man doch vorbereitet sein. Auf jeden Fall.
Baggersteuer.
Baggersteuer. Genau. Naja,
auf jeden Fall gibt es schon lange diese Klage der großen Telcos in Europa und
es bezieht sich im Wesentlichen auch nur auf die ganz großen Telcos,
also Deutsche Telekom, France Telekom, Telefonica und einen habe ich noch vergessen.
Die halt schon immer sagen so, das ist ja alles, das ist ja alles, das ist ja alles, teuer.
Es wird zwar enorm investiert in diesen Bereich, und sie sind ja auch nicht
in der Lage, die ganzen Förderungen, die es irgendwie schon gibt,
auch nur ansatzweise unter die Erde zu bekommen, aber es ist ja alles ganz teuer.
Naja, auf jeden Fall Thierry Breton ist jetzt der Meinung, es wäre alles so
ungerecht und weil der ganze Treffig,
der hier so gemacht wird, da gehen ja so 55 Prozent gehen ja so zu den Big Four oder Five.
Also Apple, Google, Facebook, die üblichen Verdächtigen, sie wissen schon.
Das ist ja sozusagen der Treffik, der geht ja nur zu denen.
Also die Hälfte quasi unserer Breitbandinfrastruktur wird von den USA verbraucht,
das ist so ein bisschen die Blickweise da drauf.
Du willst sagen, wir brauchen eine Maut, weil Leute durch Deutschland durch,
von Polen nach Frankreich fahren.
Ja, den Autobahnvergleich, den können wir gleich nochmal rausziehen.
Ich finde den ja immer ganz passend eigentlich.
Aber vielleicht erstmal, was jetzt tatsächlich passiert ist.
Also es ist jetzt eine Art Konsultationsverfahren angestoßen worden.
Das ist im Wesentlichen so eine Art Feedback-Runde auf EU-Ebene,
wo so gesagt wird so, ja, Wie wäre es denn mal so mit so einer Breitbandsteuer?
Was sagt ihr denn dazu? Und dann wird das eben so in Europa eingesammelt,
um dann eben zu einer Beschlussfassung zu gehen. Also da gibt es jetzt noch
keine fertigen Pläne, sondern das Ganze wird jetzt irgendwie diskutiert.
Das Bundesministerium für Digitales und Verkehr, wir wissen,
die Sperrspitze des Breitbandausbaus in Deutschland,
ist aber nicht so begeistert und meint, das haben schon andere probiert,
hat nicht so richtig gut funktioniert, zum Beispiel in Südkorea hat man mal
das ähnlich gemacht und das hat einfach zu einem totalen Backlash geführt,
weil weil das einfach auch dann die Märkte verunsichert.
Und naja, aber trotzdem gibt es halt die Klagen der Telcos, die der Meinung
sind, das wäre alles viel zu teuer und überhaupten wir wollen ja mitverdienen.
Und noch nicht mal mehr unsere SMS als Cashcow funktioniert derzeit.
Jetzt kann man natürlich trefflich darüber diskutieren, ob das ein berechtigtes
Anliegen ist oder nicht. Und ich glaube, das hat sehr viel damit zu tun, wie man da drauf schaut.
Es gibt halt diese Sichtweise mit, das ist ja der Traffic von Facebook und so.
Man könnte natürlich auch sagen, das ist der Traffic von Millionen von Kunden
in Europa, die hier eine Dienstleistung in Anspruch nehmen.
Ja, exakt.
Und weil das geht ja immer both ways.
Wenn es dieses Facebook nicht gäbe, würden die wahrscheinlich euer Stream on
Chat und Social nicht haben wollen.
Naja, das ist halt eher eine Geschichte
der mangelnden Attraktivität entsprechender europäischer Dienste.
Also es gibt halt einfach kein wirkliches Silicon Valley, egal wie oft irgendwelche
schwäbische Kleinstädte behaupten das dann zu sein.
Das sind die dann auch.
Lass sie doch. In ihrem eigenen Silicon-Land-Left.
Die machen damit KI, was bestimmt ganz was Tolles.
Ja, also der Mangel an Breitband hat ja unter Umständen auch dazu geführt,
dass hier sich niemand wirklich ernsthaft mit dem Internet beschäftigt hat.
Du kennst ja diese ganze Debatte.
Was ist die erste Frage, wenn man sagt, wie wäre es denn mal mit Internet?
Internet? Was sagt denn der Deutsche dann dazu?
Wofür?
Wofür braucht man das? Das ist immer die erste Frage. Ja, weiß ich,
hab ich noch nie gehabt, irgendwie, ich brauch das nicht, so ein Quatsch.
Vater Bauer nicht kennt das von mir. Immer dieses, wofür braucht man das?
Das ist die Frage, mit der kriegst du wirklich jede Innovation komplett in den
Arsch. Nicht, dass es nicht legitim wäre, Dinge zu hinterfragen,
das will ich damit jetzt überhaupt nicht sagen. nicht sagen.
Es gibt eine ganze Menge Sachen, wo ich auch sagen würde, wozu braucht man das.
Hatten wir ja auch schon ein paar, so Bitcoin und so.
Aber nicht einzusehen, dass eine digitale Infrastruktur an sich der Weg in die
Zukunft ist, dass es dann schon irgendwie etwas, das war in den 90er Jahren,
hatte es Potenzial zum Stirnrunzeln.
Das war so ab 2000 hat man sich schon gegen den Kopf gehauen und in den Zehnerjahren
war es zum Haare ausraufen und wenn irgendwie heute da irgendwer in die man
sowas noch mal auf den Tisch dann will ich mich einfach nur noch ritzen.
Warum denn? Einfach weil es alles so fassungslos war.
Blutige Stirn.
Naja, auf jeden Fall das...
Okay, aber jetzt sitzen wir hier und sagen, wir haben relativ viel Kupfer vergraben,
da pressen wir Internet durch.
Wenn wir an den wenigen Stellen, an den wenigen Stellen, wo wir Glasfaser liegen
haben, kommen Bagger und machen sie uns kaputt. Was natürlich auch,
sag ich mal, wirklich relativ zielgenauer Bagger ist.
Also wenn du dir mal die Fläche der Bundesrepublik Deutschland anguckst,
das ist echt irgendwie 80.000 im Stadion. Wer kriegt den Ball vor den Kopf,
weißt du? Es ist auch immer klar, wer das ist. Aber okay, die...
War bestimmt die Russen. Die haben hier die Bagger aufgekauft.
So jetzt jetzt sagen jetzt jetzt stellen sie fest okay diese Infrastruktur die
wir nicht gebaut haben die wollen Leute haben die geben uns Geld dafür und die
sind mit der Infrastruktur die wir hier gebaut haben nicht zufrieden weil entgegen
unserer Erwartungen brauchen die die tatsächlich oder?
Das ist jetzt eine Zusammenfassung. Ja so kann man das auch sehen.
Ich meine ich drehe Das ist mal andersrum. Sagen wir mal so, okay, geile Idee.
Lass sie zahlen, irgendwie machen wir jetzt Subventionen, kommen jetzt direkt aus den USA.
Und angenommen, wir kriegen das jetzt irgendwie einfach durch,
weil wenn die EU das jetzt beschließt, dann wäre das ja dann auch so und dann
müsstest du das machen. Also ich meine, da sehe ich jetzt erstmal eine ganze...
Also die wollen jetzt, ich glaub du musst nochmal die Idee...
Die Idee ist, dass man in den... Genau darauf wollte ich jetzt gerade hinaus.
Was könnte denn das überhaupt für eine Implementierung sein?
Also was ist jetzt sozusagen das Kriterium?
Sollen also jetzt quasi Unternehmen dafür bezahlen, dass sie quasi eine Auslastung
des Netzes verursachen?
Wer tut das? Ab wann ist das dann überhaupt eine Gleichbehandlung?
Muss dann die Metaebene auch dafür Geld bezahlen, dass Leute meinen Podcast runterladen?
Ja, überleg mal Tim, was die Deutsche Telekom hier für ein Netz bauen musste.
Damit dieser Podcast gehört werden kann.
Ja, die haben Milliarden investiert und wir machen hier hunderte Euro. Hunderte.
Wir benutzen noch nicht mal ihre Werbetracker.
Also da fängt es ja dann schon mal an. Also sie müssten ohnehin in irgendeiner
Form so ein Kriterium machen,
irgendeine windelweiche Formulierung, die so total kompliziert nach juristischem
Quatsch klingt und am Ende heißt Wir wollen, dass Facebook uns Geld gibt und Apple.
Wegen, warum so. Apple?
Apple auch? Naja. Apple Music, Apple...
Ich hätte jetzt gedacht so Netflix, Netflix...
Ja, Facebook, Google, was auch immer. Also ich meine, ich weiß jetzt nicht,
wie Apple da im Vergleich darstellt, aber...
Die ganzen unverschlüsselten iPhone Cloud-Backups.
Ja, aber wenn die schon nicht lesen können, dann wollen wir aber WC-Kohle dafür
haben. Also das ist das erste Problem.
Also irgendjemand, der Kohle hat, sagen wir mal, irgendjemand,
der Kohle hat, sagen wir mal noch nicht genau wer, aber irgendjemand,
der Kohle hat, von dem wollen wir welche. Genau.
Irgendjemand, der mit dem Internet Geld verdient im Gegensatz zu uns. Genau.
Das kann ja irgendwie auch kein Kriterium sein. Also du kannst ja nicht den
Gewinn eines Unternehmens da reinbringen. Ich meine, das A-Zahlen,
die sowieso alle keine steuern, das heißt, das kannst du jetzt nicht sein.
Und das tut schon auch nicht.
Ja auch nicht. Das ist eine super gute Idee, denen mit Steuern zu kommen. Genau.
Also wie definierst du das? Ist jetzt jedes Datenpaket, was da hingeht, so, wer erfasst das?
Wer misst denn das jetzt genau?
Und was ist das Kriterium? Sagen wir mal, das wäre jetzt alles machbar und es
wäre auch vor dem Gericht durchfechtbar, so eine Ungleichbehandlung zu machen.
Nach dem Motto, wer hier Treffik macht, der verdient auch Geld.
Also muss dann auch Wikipedia zahlen.
Dafür, dass sie gelesen werden, dass sie einen kostenlosen Dienst haben.
Oder verdienen die viel, weil sie Spenden kriegen. Also was ist hier das Kriterium?
Das ist schon mal das erste, was ich mich frage. Aber sagen wir mal,
das wäre jetzt alles gelöst und die Kohle kommt.
Dann gehen also jetzt die Milliarden von Wikipedia und der Meta eben.
Gehen jetzt auf das EU-Konto oder so.
Oder in die Staaten. Also ist das dann in Deutschland, also ist es dann da, wo der Trafik anfällt?
Ist das dann, wenn der Trafik durch Belgien auch noch durch,
also wenn ihr jetzt in Amsterdam ankommt und dann nach Deutschland geht,
muss man dann für drei Hops nochmal ein paar Prozent nach Amsterdam überweisen
und den Rest nach Deutschland oder wie? Ja, also...
Ja, die würden ja wahrscheinlich nicht pro Verbindung, aber...
Das sind aber alles berechtigte Fragen. Also wo wird denn dann sozusagen das Verbrauch?
Also wo glüht das Glas?
Erstmal glüht hier nirgendwo Glas.
Bei dem Treffik irgendwie, den alle behaupten, dass das hier verursacht,
da hat man das Gefühl, da glüht das Glas.
Die wollen ja, dass wir sorgenfrei surfen.
Also noch mehr Fragen, Verteilung, wer kriegt das,
wie viel, von wem, all das finde ich schon vollkommen, ist schon der absolute,
also meiner Meinung nach ist diese Initiative an dieser Stelle bereits beendet.
Aber sagen wir mal, die Kohle ist jetzt irgendwie da und die liegt jetzt auf
irgendeinem Säcke Und es gibt vielleicht so ein EU-Fond, der jetzt ausgegeben wird.
Wer kriegt das und wofür?
Also wer darf den dann bauen? Wer wird denn dann jetzt finanziert?
Nach welchem Schlüssel?
Telekom soll das kriegen? Warum? Wofür? Also wofür genau?
Dafür, dass sie jetzt irgendwie Fiber to the Home bauen und in irgendwelche
Städte, Dörfer, Gemeinden, Häuser ihre Internetanschlüsse reinbauen, die,
die man nur mit ihnen als Provider benutzen darf.
Also wir haben ja überhaupt gar kein liberalisiertes Anschlusssystem,
bei dem man auch nur ansatzweise darüber nachdenken könnte, Geld gleichmäßig zu verteilen.
Ich habe ja jetzt überhaupt gar kein Problem damit, dass jetzt irgendwie gesagt wird,
okay, EU-Subventionen für Netzausbau meint wegen, woher auch immer sie die Kohle
nehmen, also ob sie sich das jetzt wirklich bei den Amerikanern holen oder bei
den anderen super erfolgreichen europäischen Anbietern.
War da nicht mal was mit einer Suchmaschine? Ja, und dann wird das irgendwie verteilt.
Aber dann würde ich sagen, naja, dann muss das aber auch wirklich in Anschlüsse
gehen, die dann einem offenen Markt zur Verfügung stehen. Wo ich also,
alte Schweden-Modelle nenne ich das jetzt, gibt es auch in anderen Ländern.
Ich würde ja eigentlich erwarten, ich ziehe eine Wohnung ein.
Da kommt dann irgendwie so eine Glasfaser aus der Wand,
beziehungsweise kommt keine Glasfaser aus der Wand,
da ist eine Glasfaser in der Wand, da ist dann so eine Ethernet-Steckdose oder
vielleicht auch schon mit einem WLAN Access Point sozusagen so serienmäßig,
so wird das so künftig ja irgendwann mal sein vielleicht,
zumindest mal so eine Ethernet-Dose, sagen wir mal so, wo du was reinstecken
kannst und das erste Mal, wo du deinen Computer da anschließt,
kommt zu so einer Webseite hoch und sagt, hallo, ich bin's, dein Internetanschluss,
welchen Provider hätten's denn gern?
Und dann kriegst du da so eine scrollbare Liste von 30.000 Anbietern,
die dir irgendwie Internet geben, mit Preis. Und dann klickst du drauf und sagst,
heute hol ich mir das mal bei, so insert your Favorite Provider hier.
So, sowas müsste es geben. Für sowas würde ich so ein Geld dann auch verteilen
und sagen, okay, jetzt bauen wir mal die Infrastruktur aus. Aber dass das dann
so hintenrum an diese Unternehmen verteilt wird, da sehe ich überhaupt keine…
Überzeugt eben nicht, ne?
Weißt du, Tim, weißt du, wie mir das vorkommt?
Das ist eine Neiddebatte.
Aber sowas von.
Eine Neiddebatte, oder? Ja, ne ne ne, du Erfolgreiter, ne ne ne ne.
Ohne meinen Kupfer hättet ihr niemals die Kunden. Also es ist so,
ja man, dann mach doch halt Facebook. Dann geh doch hin und mach Facebook.
Wenn du meinst, du kannst das besser. Ja, dann mach doch das.
Zwingt dich doch niemand bei der Deutschen Telekom, Kupfer zu vergraben.
Als das Thema für die Sendung kam, muss ich sagen, dass ich spontan auch gar
nicht mal so unsympathisch fand auf den ersten Blick.
Ich dachte, naja, okay, irgendjemand muss hier mal ein Netz bauen und vielleicht
versuchen wir einfach, von dem Geld zu erpressen, um das zu bezahlen.
Wir sitzen ja hier auch wirklich mit einem zunehmenden Problem.
Wie dieses Kind da in Niedersachsen, das ist eine Story, den muss ich jetzt
noch mal in die Sendung bringen.
Irgendwo in Niedersachsen ist ein 1,20 Meter großes neunjähriges Kind in der
Bank und wollte Geld haben. Hat es nicht bekommen. Aber ich meine,
Punkte dafür, dass es versucht hat. So. Ich denke, das ist es.
Und ich denke, lustig daran ist, dass das jetzt ernsthaft eine Polizeifahndung auslöst.
Wahrscheinlich befindet sich dahinter eine relativ tragische Situation.
Und so sehe ich jetzt auch unseren Thierry Breton da, der sagt,
okay, Scheiße, ich versuche jetzt einfach mal, die Sparkasse zu erpressen.
Und dann wird halt nach einem Kind mit einer Rentiermütze gefahndet.
Ungefähr so stelle ich mir auch die Reaktion von Google und Facebook vor und sagen so,
der rannte irgendwie nach Europa, der ist über den Atlantik abgehauen. Weißt du?
Ja, so was hat es. Ich meine, ich habe das glaube ich auch schonmal angebracht,
aber ich bin nun kein großer Freund und Fan von Helmut Kohl gewesen.
Schon damals nicht und auch so nach nachgang ne
nicht also wurde doch so viel für uns
getan hat ja aber
er ist er ist er ist irgendwie mal er hatte ja auch mal so sein neuland moment
für den er viel gescholten wurde aber ich fand dass er eigentlich aus unwissend
aus unwissendheit heraus die wahrheit gesagt hat ja die sache mit der Datenautobahn.
Und was hat er gemacht mit Leon Kirch? Koaxial Kabel verlegt.
Wie gesagt, kein großer Fan von Helmut Kohl, aber in diesem Moment,
als er irgendwie nach der Datenautobahn gefragt wurde und gar nicht wusste,
worum es irgendwie geht.
Egal, auf jeden Fall dieser Begriff Datenautobahn finde ich...
Ist eigentlich ganz geil, weil er nämlich einen schönen Vergleich zieht zwischen
Straßeninfrastruktur und Internetinfrastruktur.
Und wenn man sich dann halt mal anschaut, wie dieser Breitbandausbau,
also wie jetzt sozusagen, unsere Straßen sollen jetzt dadurch finanziert werden,
indem die, die da am meisten drauf rumfahren, bezahlen.
Also es wäre da wahrscheinlich DHL, weil die unsere Pakete durch die Gegend bringen.
Die fahren auch nicht auf der Autobahn, die fahren irgendwie Motor an Motor aus durch die Bietung.
Na ja, die fahren halt auch zwischendurch über die Autobahn, so ist es nicht.
Stimmt, irgendwie kommt das Paket ja auch so.
Es geht ja auch nicht nur um die Autobahn, es geht generell um Straßen.
Und so kriegst du einfach kein Wirtschaftsmodell hin. Infrastruktur heißt,
man baut einen, wie sagt man so schön, Plain Level Field, Das war der falsche Begriff.
Level Playing Fields, auf dem dann alle ihre Chancen wahrnehmen können.
Und natürlich ist dieser Blick auf das Internet derzeit ganz stark geprägt von,
oh mein Gott, die werden wir alle nicht mehr los.
Und wahrscheinlich werden wir manche von den Großen auch nicht mehr los.
Aber dass das auch alles ganz schnell zu Ende sein kann, haben wir auch schon ein paar Mal gesehen.
Also der Glaube, das wäre jetzt alles so in Stein gemeißelt, ist Quatsch.
Aber dazu braucht es halt auch ein offenes, kompetitives System.
Und ich glaube nicht, dass es am Geld liegt. Ich glaube, es liegt an anderen
Sachen. Das liegt vor allem daran, dass wir diesen großen Telekom viel zu viel
Gestaltungsfreiheit und politischen Protektionismus bereitstellen.
Und ja, und sie damit davon kommen lassen, eine nicht ausreichende Infrastruktur
zu teuren Preisen anzubieten. Aber Tim, ich muss eine Sache sagen.
Ich habe Datenautobahn gegoogelt.
Datenautobahn hat einen eigenen Wikipedia-Eintrag. Er hat einen eigenen Kapitel-Ursprung.
Und der ganzen Seite kommt Kohl nicht vor.
Wirklich nicht? Warum nicht?
Nein. 1993 Clinton-Gohr haben irgendwie vom National Information Infrastructure,
Global Information Infrastructure und so weiter Ausdruck Information,
Highway, Hochgeschwindigkeit setzten, aber Coal kommt nicht vor.
Deutsch inhaltlich bedeutete Information Highway dasselbe, was in der Bundesrepublik
Breitsheit in den 70er Jahren gedacht war.
Ein integriertes, bereitbeiniges undiversale Netz mit Funktionen wie der Vernetzung
aller Schulen und Bibliotheken sowie später von Dienst wie dem kommerziellen
Vertrieb digitaler Videos, Video und Demar und interaktives Fernseh,
Tele-Shopping und Videokonferenz über IP.
Datenautobahn wurde dann eine Folge-Diskussion geführt, angetrieben durch die
Berichterstattung in den Mediennamen die Präsenz von Begriffen wie Datenautobahn
und Multimedia auch im deutschen Sprachraum ab etwa 1994 kontinuierlich zu.
Also ich habe es auch noch mal nachgeschlagen. Ich habe es auch ein bisschen
verdreht, aber es wurde ihm dann sozusagen häufig Ich weiß nicht ganz genau
wie es ihm nachgetragen wurde, wie auch immer auf jeden Fall.
Er wurde Er hat es irgendwann auch mal gesagt.
Hans Meiser in der Sendung nachgefragt und ein Microsoft Mitarbeiter hat ihn
nach der Datenautobahn gefragt und das hat er nicht verstanden.
Genau das. Und hat gesagt für
den Bau von Autobahnen sind dem Bund hauptsächlich die Länder zuständig.
Ja, das deckt sich eher.
Aber schön, dass du ihm trotzdem noch mal einen Punkt gegeben hast.
Ich hatte das so in Erinnerung. Das ist immer so eine selektive Wahrnehmung.
Es wäre auf jeden Fall, sagen wir mal so, es wäre vielleicht gut,
wenn wir da jetzt nicht auch noch eine Ländersache draus machen.
Das wäre in der Tat ein echtes Problem.
Also insofern habe ich auch überhaupt kein Problem damit, wenn die EU sagt,
hier mit dem Netzausbau geht es nicht voran, hätte ich einen guten Tipp irgendwie.
Ja, einfach schön die Zugänge komplett liberalisieren, da irgendwie einen freien
Wettbewerb beim Anbieterkram machen.
Überall wo das so nur so ein bisschen stattgefunden hat, hat sich in der Regel
eine ganze Menge getan. Alle Städte in Deutschland, alle Kommunen,
die dafür mehr Wettbewerb gesorgt haben, haben in der Regel davon profitiert.
Es ist aber bei diesem Bau von digitaler Infrastruktur ja in Deutschland ohnehin verrückt.
Ich meine wir bauen vier Mobilfunknetze parallel.
Genau das ist es. Und bei To The Home ist es halt genau das selbe.
Nur dass du nicht vier Anschlüsse in dein Haus rein kriegst,
aber nur einen der Anbieter benutzen kannst.
Mir würde eine Loopmuffe To The Home reichen.
Also Endpunkte müssen einfach, wie sagt man, verstaatlicht werden.
Vernetzt werden, vernetzt. Ach so, verstaatlich, hör auf. Pssst,
die spielen uns den Podcast.
Wenn wir jetzt als nächstes enteignen, wir die Deutsche Telekom. Na ja.
Gar nicht so eine schlechte Idee, oder? Es ist auf jeden Fall was zu holen.
So, wir haben auf jeden Fall den Link auf Helmut Kohl's Kommentar.
Oh, noch bitte den Show noch.
Wollen wir das noch kurz einspielen?
Kann ich das so schnell einspielen? Ich schneide das hier nachher noch rein.
Okay, alles klar.
Okay, damit kommen wir zu dem Ergebnis, Ländersache ist es nicht,
aber EU-Sache wahrscheinlich auch nicht und irgendwie jetzt hier zu einem einen
Zwang irgendwie zu versuchen zu schaffen,
dass Unternehmen, die in einem ganz anderen Land irgendetwas anbieten,
jetzt hier für den Bau der Infrastruktur verpflichtet werden.
Ich meine, da können wir froh sein, wenn die Amis uns nicht bombardieren.
Also das ist ja wirklich die Idee, ja, also die Idee für irgendwelche privatwirtschaftlichen
Konzerne auf EU-Ebene jetzt von den Inhalteanbietern irgendwas erpressen zu
wollen und zu denken, damit kommst du durch.
Also es ist so dieser gleiche Gedanke wie beim Leistungsschutzrecht,
wo dann irgendwie sich ein paar Presseverleger gedacht haben,
der Google, der wäre doch gar nichts ohne uns.
Wir kriegen allen Traffic über Google. Also... ist...
Sind wir auch der Grund, dass Google Traffic hat. So, nein. Nur weil 90 Prozent
von eurem Traffic von Google kommen, heißt das noch lange nicht,
dass 90 Prozent des Traffics von Google von euch kommen.
Das ist ein super Vergleich. Weißt du, das bedeutet sozusagen,
was die da planen ist ein Leitungsschutzrecht.
Das ist doch unsere Leitung!
Leitungsschutzrecht, das ist das gleiche wie Leistungsschutzrecht,
nur ohne Leistung. Noch nicht mal eine Leitungsschutzrecht. Ja,
wunderschön, Leitungsschutzrecht.
Wir haben heute auch echt lange gebraucht, um Sendungstätigkeiten zu finden.
Tja, solange müssen wir halt unsere Witze machen.
Ah, schön.
Dann können wir weitermachen.
Okay. Jetzt kommen wir endlich zum nächsten Thema. Wir haben T.L.
So jetzt alles die Sendung ist schon mal trocken.
Wir kommen mit ein paar schlechte Nachrichten einstreuen.
Also Quad 9. Wir haben mit Felix, glaube ich, über dieses Thema gesprochen.
Felix Reeder, GFF, habe ich gerade schon mal erwähnt. Als Sachverständiger gegen die Chatkontrolle.
Als Sachverständiger zum Thema Chatkontrolle im Deutschen Bundestag,
Digitalausschuss, die schon länger die Sendung hören, erinnern sich, also diese Folge hören.
Und der hat uns davon erzählt, dass Quad9, also ein von einer gemeinnützigen Schweizer Stiftung.
Betriebener DNS-Server, DNS-Serverbetreiber, ja, ein betriebener Betreiber,
die bieten also DNS-Server an unter der IP-Adresse 9999,
deswegen Quad9 und wenn man diesen Server benutzt,
dann kann man dort als besondere Funktion irgendwie Sperrung von malicious haben,
was teilweise gar nicht so schlecht ist, wenn man vielleicht einfach mal so
ein Unternehmensnetz oder auch nur sein Heimnetz schützen möchte.
Die haben eine einstweilige Verfügung in Hamburg kassiert,
natürlich, denn sowas macht man dann eben beim Amtsgericht Hamburg und die haben,
und zwar hat Sony gesagt, ihr sperrt bitte auf eurem DNS-Server zwei Einträge,
weil die führen auf Webseiten, wo man Hinweise findet, wie man Musik illegal
herunterladen kann, die uns gehört.
Und deswegen seid ihr schuld, dass Leute das im Internet besuchen können und
deswegen sperrt ihr die jetzt.
So. Und die sind aber natürlich nicht zu Google gegangen,
die den großen Webse einen sehr bekannten DNS-Service unter der IP-Adresse 8888
anbieten oder zu Cloudfair, die das gleiche unter 1111 anbieten.
Sondern die haben sich schön irgendwie so einen kleinen, gemeinnützigen Stiftungs-DNS-Server
genommen und haben gesagt,
die haben glaube ich nicht die richtigen Anwälte und die zählen wir jetzt aus
Zürich nach Hamburg und hauen den da mal richtig einfach auf die Fresse.
Bei uns, bei unseren Hamburger Gerichten, wo wir wissen, da zählt Urheberrecht
irgendwie mehr als, mehr als alles andere. und.
Jetzt muss ich sagen, dass ich den juristischen Teil hier gar nicht vollständig verstehe,
weil es gibt die Einsweilige in Hamburg, dann gibt es, wenn man sich dann gegen die Einsweilige wehrt,
dann gibt es eine, also diese Einsweilige war natürlich die Sperranordnung,
wenn man sich gegen die wehrt, dann gibt es da eine Urteil,
da hat das Landgericht Hamburg gegen Quad 9 entschieden und hat gesagt,
Sony hat Recht, da läuft jetzt die Berufung vor dem Hamburger Oberlandesgericht,
also vom Landgericht ging es dann zum Oberlandesgericht.
Amtsgericht war gar nicht beteiligt, es war direkt das Landgericht Hamburg.
Ich habe gerade kurz Amtsgericht gesagt, also Landgericht war es.
Und jetzt gab es noch ein Hauptsacheverfahren in Leipzig.
Und die GFF und Quad9 haben argumentiert, ey, du bist bei uns falsch,
irgendjemand stellt im Internet eine Dienstleistung zur Verfügung.
Wir sind eines von vielen Telefonbüchern zu diesem Internet.
Du hast überhaupt keinen Anspruch an uns, irgendjemand aus dem Telefonbuch zu
streichen, nur weil du das nicht willst. Wo kämen wir denn dahin?
Und insbesondere kannst du uns sicherlich nicht als Täter, also Schuldiger an
dieser Urheberrechtsverletzung, belangen.
Und sowieso auch nicht als Störer, weil wir haben ja mit diesen Inhalten überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Und jetzt sagt das Leipziger Gericht,
naja, wir haben uns überlegt, das Telemediengesetz,
auf das ihr euch beruft, danach ist Quad9 überhaupt nicht zu belangen,
denn weder der Betreiber dieses Resolvers noch der Domain-Registrar noch der
Admin C halten diese Informationen ja selber bereit oder vermitteln den Zugang.
Denn die Domäne selber, die ist ja überhaupt nicht bei Quad9 registriert.
Die sagen ja nur, irgendjemand hat diese Domäne und wir wissen das vom DNS-System
und geben diese Information weiter.
Deswegen aber, weil sie nur Informationen weiterleiten, ist Quad9 nach Ansicht
dieser Leipziger Richter kein Dienstanbieter im Sinne des TMG und hätte deswegen
auch keinen Anspruch auf Haftungsprivilegierung.
Was ich glaube ein katastrophaler Fehler ist. Also das ist sowas von dumm.
Gerade wenn du doch nicht für diese Inhalte verantwortlich bist,
musst du doch von der Haftung frei stehen.
Aber die Leipziger sagen Dienstanbieter ist nur wer durch seine Weisungen oder
seine Herrschaftsmacht über Rechner und Kommunikationskanäle die Verbreitung
oder Speichern von Informationen ermöglicht und nach außen als Erbringer von Diensten auftritt.
Und das sei bei Quot9 nicht der Fall.
Das ist so Richterlogik.
Und deswegen sei das einzige zutreffende Gesetz das Urheberrechtsgesetz.
Und deswegen ist Nein, nicht Störer, weil die sagen, wo man diese Webseite findet, sondern Täter.
Und die müssen jetzt 200.000 Euro Ordnungsgeld bzw.
Zwei Jahre Haft in Aussicht gestellt bekommen, wenn sie, also das ist die Androhung
der Strafe, wenn sie weiterhin zwei verwandte Domains in die zugehörigen IP-Adressen übersetzen.
Und diese beiden Domains, die dürfen sie jetzt nicht mehr auflösen,
weil, also die Das kannst du dir doch gar nicht vorstellen.
Also wie kann denn ein so dermaßen dummes Urteil gefällt werden?
Ich frage mich gerade, ob jetzt irgendwie auch, ob die jetzt mit derselben Logik
auch Telefonbücher irgendwie verklagt hätten?
Ja, ja, absolut. Also und interessanterweise bei dem etwas älteren Artikel ist auch genau der Punkt,
dass nur, also nur weil jemand einen Telefonanschluss hat,
heißt es ja nicht, dass du den ins Telefonbuch schreiben sollst und wenn das
einem Dritten nicht gefällt, dann darfst du den eben nicht ins Telefonbuch schreiben.
Noch dazu, die führen das Telefonbuch ja nicht. Also die ganze Nummer ist sowas
von... Also das ist sowas von...
Also ich kann mir das nicht anders erklären. Die haben das ja überhaupt nicht
verstanden, wie diese Technologie funktioniert.
Ich muss an den Film denken hier mit dem Pavel,
Billion Dollar Code, wo dann irgendwie der Sachverständige den Sachverhalt einfach
auf eine Weise vorträgt, dass ihn niemand versteht.
Aber das kann ja auch nicht sein, weil die GFF, die haben ja kluge Leute da
sitzen. Felix Reeder hat uns den Fall doch erklärt in den besten Beispielen.
Ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen, wie man in Hamburg und in Leipzig auf so
eine skurrile Interpretation der Rechtssituation kommt.
Es ist so ein bisschen Richtergesetzes-Jurallogik.
Weil hier ein Gesetz herangezogen wird, das Ausnahmen schafft.
Die Vorgeschichte ist ja im Prinzip die ganze TMG-Definition,
die für einen ganz anderen Fall definiert war und die jetzt angewendet wird
und nicht die passenden Entscheidungsvorschriften liefert für den Fall,
weil der sich da überhaupt nicht drin abbildet.
Dann schauen sie da halt einfach nur mit dieser Gesetzeslogik drauf,
weil das ist nur mal das, was man so macht als Richter.
Ja, und dann so, ja, ne, das ist ja, also ihr seid ja nicht das,
dann, dann, dann müsste ja zwangsläufig was anderes sein, weil das wird ja dann
hier nicht ausreichend beschrieben. Also nehmen wir das nächste Gesetz,
was uns hier irgendwie angemessen erscheint.
So, und dann, wenn er erstmal Urheberrecht im Spiel ist, dann ist immer alles vorbei.
Jetzt kommt als nächstes noch der Vollidiot mit seiner Tammene da.
No.
Also, okay, schwieriger, schwierig, gefährlich. Und was Felix uns ja damals
auch schon erklärt hat, Sony sucht natürlich hier nach Präzedenz.
Die haben hier ganz klar... Die hätten sich ja auch einfach mal mit Google anlegen können.
Und das bei denen versuchen können. Da wissen sie aber, dass Google sich ähnlich
viele Anwälte und Recherche gönnt.
Also knallen sie auf eine gemeinnützige Schweizer Stiftung,
um letztendlich ihren Beknackten diese Webseiten zu sperren,
als wenn 2023 noch irgendjemand wirklich MP3s runterlädt.
Das ist so richtig mutwillig-böswilliger Raubbau.
Zerstörungswut, Rache am Internet. weil Spotify Geld verdient und nicht wir,
weil wir mit Ron Sommer gesagt haben, man braucht kein Internet oder so.
Also das ist doch alles, das ist doch die gleiche Schiene.
Also ich finde es wirklich schwer nachvollziehbar.
Aber okay, haben wir hiermit berichtet.
Kommen wir zum Tanz auf den Vulkan.
Ja, ich habe. Es geht.
Also da ist noch was, da läuft noch was schief im Internet.
Im 2019 war es glaube ich oder 2018 oder so. Also ich habe mit THS mal einen
Vortrag auf dem Congress gehalten.
Der Titel war, du kannst alles hacken, du darfst dich nur nicht erwischen lassen.
Und Der ist also auf jeden Fall ein paar Jahre alt, vier Jahre oder so.
Und den hat jetzt ein Kolumnist von der Kronen-Zeitung gefunden.
Krone.at, das ist die Zeitung, die der Strache von der Roten Kaufe wollte.
Die, ja.
Hat nicht geklappt. Und deswegen, jetzt hat ein Kolumnist diesen Vortrag gefunden.
Eine Kolumne auf KRONE.at geschrieben. Und ich will jetzt,
die ist wirklich zuckersüß, ich empfehle dir auf jeden Fall den Hörer mal zu
lesen, denn, keine Ahnung, auf jeden Fall kommt er am Ende zu dem Schluss.
Neumanns Blogs sind ein Tanz auf dem Vulkan. Im Grunde gibt er der Community
laufend Ratschläge für ein Hacken, das die Polizei austrickst.
Schöne neue Welt. Immerhin hat er den Vortrag verstanden, würde ich sagen.
Also das kann man schon mal ein wunderschön...
Ich werde ja außerdem als Lichtgestalt bezeichnet.
Ja, da hat man ja schon gemerkt, dass das was nicht in Ordnung ist.
Und als leuchtendes Vorbild.
Wirklich. Unser aller leuchtendes Vorbild beim Chaos-Computer-Gespräch.
Ihr leuchtendes Vorbild ist Linus Neumann, der im September 2017,
wenige Wochen vor der deutschen Bundestagswahl ein Papier veröffentlichte,
wonach die Software erhebliche Sicherheitslücken aufweise und Angriffspfade
zur Manipulation der Wahldaten biete.
Stimmt, ja, also alles richtig gestaltet.
Schöne Neuwelt. Turt durch YouTube und andere Lande.
Ja, alles.
International. Ture YouTube. Ja, verdammt, Autobahn.
YouTube reisen.
Fand ich auf jeden Fall sehr schön, dass es so später Aufmerksamkeit für diesen
Artikel kam. Das wollte ich mal kurz mit angeben.
So, jetzt kommen wir mal zu was Ernstes. Xhain. Xhain ist den Berliner Hackerinnen
und Hackern sicherlich bekannt seit, boah, inzwischen auch. Aber die müssten
auch bald zehn Jahre alt werden.
Oder sind die schon zehn Jahre alt? Gibt es schon eine Weile,
ja, in der Tat. Ich weiß es gar nicht. Gute Frage.
Hätte jetzt so 2012, 2013, 2013, 14, vielleicht 12, 13, 14, irgendwann wurde
die X-Hain gegründet. befindet sich in Berlin Friedrichshain in.
Was ist das da? Grünberger Straße, ne? Oder ist das Grünberger?
Ja, ich würde sagen Grünberger Straße wahrscheinlich.
Und da haben sich ein paar Leute zusammengetan, haben einen Hacker und Makerspace gemacht.
In so einer Gewerbefläche.
Also mit einem Schaufenster draußen, kannst rein.
Und die haben es geschafft. da finde ich eine sehr nette, offene Kultur zu schaffen.
Vielleicht eine, für die jetzt nicht alle Making- und Hacking-Spaces davor unbedingt
jetzt herausragend bekannt waren.
Findet relativ viel statt. Da gehen regelmäßig auch irgendwie Jugendhacklabs
und wenn man da so vorbeikommt, sind da Leute und machen was.
Es ist schon ein ziemlich gelungenes Projekt. Da haben wir übrigens auch hier
Zerforschungen und ich,
wir haben doch letztes, vorletztes Jahr oder wann da für den Remote Congress
da so einen Vortrag gemacht, über Sicherheitslücken melden, den haben wir da gedreht.
Und ja, jetzt haben die davon erfahren, dass quasi diese Gewerbeeinheit,
die sie da bezogen haben, verkauft werden soll. Und da haben sie natürlich Sorge,
wer so etwas kauft, kauft es potenziell mit einem Gewinninteresse.
Gewinninteresse heißt Mietsteigerung und wenn jetzt eine Gewerbefläche,
da hast du in der Regel, das ist jetzt nicht so was wie ein Kündigungsschutz
und auch keine langfristig vereinbarten Mieten, die jetzt nicht irgendwie nach
Gutdünken einfach erhöht werden können.
Können. Das heißt, die haben jetzt Sorge, dass sie da früher oder später eben
fliegen und sie wollen sich bemühen, die Bude nun zu kaufen.
Sie haben ein Vorkaufsrecht und gehen davon aus,
dass sie für diesen Kauf, also unter Inanspruchnahme des Vorkaufsrechtes und Kaufnebenkosten,
die ja bei Kauf von Immobilien, was sind das nochmal so 8% oder sowas,
dass dass sie da so in der Region von 700.000.
Euro landen.
Und meinen, dass sie, wenn sie jetzt so die Hälfte von dem Geld in Spenden zusammen hätten,
schuld denken sie, dass sie jetzt in der Lage sind, dann einen Kredit aufzunehmen
mit diesem Verein, um den Rest dann eben in Raten zu zahlen.
Und ich finde das, also auf Anhieb habe ich gedacht, boah Leute,
dann zieht doch einfach um.
Aber ich kann schon verstehen, wenn wir solche Spaces in Berlin erhalten wollen
und wenn du nicht irgendwie,
weißt du hier so wie in Ulm,
das Verschwörhaus, dann am Ende aus deiner Location von der Stadt rausgescheucht
werden willst und dann auf der Suche bist sind irgendwelche Streitereien,
da muss man eben auch mal einfach irgendwann mal so ein Flock in den Boden rammen
und sagen, das sichern wir uns jetzt hier langfristig.
Wir haben hier was geschaffen und wir wollen das auch behalten und weiter gestalten.
Und wenn du das nicht machst, ja, dann kommt eben früher oder später irgendjemand
und macht es dir kaputt. Irgendeine externe Entität.
Und ja. Anmerkungen vielleicht noch dazu.
Also erstmal Gründung Mai 2016, also noch keine ganzen zehn Jahre,
aber sieben Jahre sind es dann bald auch. Und es ist auch kein Verein,
sondern es ist eine gemeinnützige UG.
Ja, das war mir bekannt.
Weil du gerade Verein gesagt hast.
Hätte ich gewusst. Ja, Vereinigung. Genau.
Nee, aber genau, die sind eine gemeinnützige UG, aber wahrscheinlich,
aber sind die echt, nee, die müssen früher da gewesen sein.
Steht auf der Webseite.
Wurde im Mai 2016 gegründet. Vielleicht ist die Information falsch,
aber das ist zumindest die offizielle Information.
Aber wer schon mal da war, wird auch gesehen haben, das ist jetzt nicht einfach
nur so ein Raum, wo irgendwie drei Tische drin stehen und dann wird da gehackt
und so, sondern das ist halt wirklich schon auch ein extrem ausgebauter und
wirklich, wirklich gut ausgestatteter Ort.
Also da ist eine Menge Gerät und Apparat am Start, Also von irgendwie Lasercutten
mit irgendwie Hobelbank und Drehmaschine und also alles kann man da sozusagen bauen.
Gibt es auch hier und da in anderen Mecha Spaces, aber du hast es auch nicht
unbedingt immer so, dass auch alles wirklich am Start ist, nutzbar ist,
ja, gepflegt und im Prinzip jederzeit verwendbar ist.
Und solche Orte ziehen natürlich auch eine ganze Menge Community an,
die dann eben so das alles mitträgt und ein Ortswechsel ist immer schwierig.
Also wenn du, klar, ein paar Straßen weiter und die haben ja auch schon mal einen Umzug gemacht,
da ging es nur irgendwie um ein paar Meter, das war super, aber in dem Moment wo du halt,
keine Ahnung, jetzt in Berlin dich dann auf einmal genötigt siehst,
was weiß ich, nach Lichtenberg zu gehen, weil da dann erst wieder Räumlichkeiten
zu holen sind, dann stirbt da auch automatisch mindestens die Hälfte der Community mit.
Und viele haben halt dort auch gesagt, so der Umzug schon, die paar Meter,
die wir einmal gemacht haben, das war schon so krass.
Um das alles wieder so herzurichten, das ist einfach ein glühender Palast.
Also da ist einfach Technik am Start, da ist ein Bars reingebaut.
Das ist jetzt nicht einfach nur so leerer Raum und man packt das alles mal in
einen Lastwagen, sondern der ist halt ausgebaut und toll.
Wie auch bei der C-Base, kannst du auch nicht so ohne weiteres zerpflücken und
woanders neu gründen, da gehört der Raum auch schon so ein bisschen mit dazu.
Naja, das spielt halt jetzt hier eine Rolle. Also wer unterstützen möchte,
kann das gerne tun und sollte das auch tun.
Informationen in unseren Show Notes.
Ja, das wird ein hartes Brot und die müssen, dass glaube ich,
wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, bis Mai geklärt haben,
dann endet dieses Vorkaufsrichter.
Also es ist ein Angebot des Verkäufers, sozusagen, also des Besitzers,
der will es halt irgendwie zu Geld machen, ist ja auch nachvollziehbar.
Und hat aber gesagt, naja, okay, wenn ihr es kauft, dann könnt ihr es haben,
dann kriegt ihr es auch ein bisschen billiger, so, aber wenn ihr es halt nicht
habt, dann geht es auf den Markt.
Und das wird dann aber dann in ein, zwei Monaten stattfinden.
Wie schnell es dann verkauft wird, ist noch mal eine andere Sache,
aber dann ist der Zug halt auch abgefahren.
Gemeinnützige UG ist hier der wichtige Punkt. Das bedeutet, du kannst deine
Spende von der Steuer absetzen.
Das haben wir ja hier schon mal erklärt. Und wenn ihr eine größere Spende,
zum Beispiel über 5000 Euro tätigen möchtet oder zum Beispiel euch nur bei Erreichen
einer Mindestspendenhöhe beteiligen möchtet,
Das wäre so eine Option, die ab einer gewissen Betrag natürlich eine Rolle spielt.
Wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel sagt, komm, ich werfe da mal 200 in den Sack,
das wird dir dem Ziel des Kaufs nicht so viel näher bringen,
aber das ist natürlich auf jeden Fall ein Geldbetrag, mit dem Sie am Ende was Gutes anfangen werden.
Und sei es nur, eine Robbe mieten für den Umzug.
Aber wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel sagt, ich habe 10.000 Euro zu viel verdient
letztes Jahr, die müssen jetzt mal weg.
Und man möchte vielleicht nicht, dass die sich die, man möchte vielleicht so
sagen, das wäre schon ganz gut, wenn, also für den Fall, dass ihr das kauft,
wäre bei diesem Betrag vielleicht so eine kleine Zweckbindung nicht schlecht.
Dass ich sage, nur wenn das zustande kommt und wenn ihr das kauft,
dann gebe ich euch 10, 20, 30, 40, 60, 80.000 Euro, was man so zu viel verdient,
ist ja unterschiedlich.
Und dann kann man damit mit denen darüber sprechen.
Und mit der Quittung gibt es dann eben, fällt auf diesen Betrag dann eben auch
keine Einkommensteuer an.
Das heißt, je nachdem, wie hoch der Einkommensteuersatz ist,
kann man hier quasi auf sehr viel,
man muss auf sehr viel weniger wirkliches Einkommen verzichten,
also sehr viel weniger Geld, was euch tatsächlich zur Verfügung stündet,
als ihr hier in der Lage seid, dem guten Zweck zu Spenden.
Du Steuerfuckst du. Erster Mai.
Und, ach so, vielleicht das ist sehr wichtig, Stand 27.2.,
haben sie schon 45.000 Euro gesammelt. Das ist ein ziemlich gutes Zeichen,
weil eine richtige Spendenkampagne haben sie noch gar nicht.
Und das zeigt ja sicherlich auch, denke ich, das wäre hier so vielleicht für Spenderinnen,
Das entscheidende Signal zu sehen, okay, selbst ohne viel Bohai sind die schon mal in der Lage,
vermutlich aus eigenen Kräften, vielleicht von den Mitgliedern,
die einen Job haben oder länger einen Job haben oder Karriere,
dass die da schon mal eben so aus eigener Kraft schon mal 45 auf den Tisch legen,
das ist ja schon mal nicht schlecht.
Und ich denke, dieser Stand wird sich aktualisieren, der ist jetzt schon mal fünf Tage alt.
Kann man mal im Auge behalten. Wer sicherlich nicht verkehrt,
das Ding mal langfristig zu sichern.
So, was haben wir noch?
Das ist nur ganz kurz, ja, also fragt den Staat.
Ihr erinnert euch an die Kampagne, fragt den Bundestag. Ein bisschen länger
her, aber ich glaube, das hat Arne Semsrott uns auch hier dann erzählt.
2015 hat das Bundesverwaltungsgericht entschieden, dass der wissenschaftliche
Dienst des Bundestags unter das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz fällt.
Und dann hat Abgeordneten Watch eine IFG-Anfrage gestellt, 2016,
nach der Übersicht der Gutachten.
Und dann hat Frag den Staat zusammen mit Abgeordneten Watch die Kampagne Frag
den Bundestag gemacht. Da gab es dann die Liste aller Gutachten.
Und man konnte mit wenigen Klicks die dort anfragen.
Und der Trick hier war eben nur, weil die auf, also die waren zwar unter das
Informationsfreiheitsgesetz, das heißt auf Anfrage müssen die rausgegeben werden,
aber nicht einfach mal direkt öffentlich gemacht werden.
Und dann hat aber innerhalb von drei Tagen mit dieser Kampagne wurden 1100 Gutachten
überfragt, den Staat angefragt.
Und dann haben sie gesagt, scheiße, jetzt müssen wir 1.500 Informationsfreiheitsanfragen
bearbeiten. vielleicht wäre es einfacher, wenn wir gut öffentlichen.
Und dann hat der Ältestenrat des Bundestages entschlossen, ja,
nee, komm, dann veröffentlichen wir einfach alles.
Ein großartiger Erfolg des Fragteen-Starteams auf der Bundestagswebseite.
Dann haben sie ihre Seite sehr gut achten gemacht, wo die im Volltext als Open
Data bereitstellen und dann haben sie noch den Landtag Rheinland-Pfalz verklagt
und so weiter, sodass jetzt immer mehr Gutachten veröffentlicht werden.
Das ist also die ganze Vorgeschichte, fragt den Staat wissenschaftlich Gutachten.
Und dann haben sie jetzt gesagt, jetzt wurden halt viele Sachen veröffentlicht,
aber einige Sachen wurden geschwärzt.
Gutachten zu Völkerrecht und deutschen Waffenexporten, Rechtsverstößen des Verkehrsministeriums,
Grundrechtseingriffe bei der Chat-Kontrolle.
So diese Einschätzung der Gutacht des Wissenschaftlichen Dienstes haben natürlich
ein relativ hohes Gewicht in der öffentlichen Debatte und jetzt soll natürlich
alles veröffentlicht werden.
Aber Es gibt insgesamt über 10.000 solcher Gutachten in den letzten 15 Jahren.
Und jetzt haben die wiederum eine Anfrage gesagt, sagen wir mal bitte alle Ausarbeitungen, die es gibt.
Und da gibt es dann welche, die sind als Verschlusssache nur für den Dienstgebrauch eingestuft worden.
Und die hat, fragt den Staat jetzt, einfach auch nochmal veröffentlicht,
damit da einfach keine Lücken entstehen für die Öffentlichkeit.
Und das finde ich sehr gut. Die von uns nun veröffentlichten Gutachten behandeln
unter anderem die Impfstoffbeschaffung,
heikles Thema, die Amtsausstattung des Bundespräsidenten und die Enteignung
ausländischen Staatsvermögens Der Bundestag hat sie nach unserer Anfrage und
unserem Widerspruch entweder teilweise geschwärzt herausgegeben oder die Einstufung
als Verschlusssache aufgehoben.
Also haben sie jetzt gesagt, nicht dass da nachher was fehlt.
Stell dir mal vor, es gibt 15.000 Pokémon und dir fehlen fünf.
Das kannst du mit einem Semmsrott nicht machen.
Das geht einfach. Alright. Und entsprechend das hier dann auch schön geguckt,
dass dir dann wenigstens geschwärzt wird, was nicht alles.
Nicht, dass da irgendwas fehlt. Ja. Die hauen halt die ganze Zeit weiter durch,
da fragt er den Staat. Naja. Schön, schön.
So, Schluss mit Sendung.
Ja, Sichtgestalt und Tim machen Ende.
Hab ich auch so einen schönen Namen, von dem ich nichts mehr weiß?
Weißt du nicht deinen Namen, wie man dich hinter deinem Rücken nennt?
Es gibt verschiedenste Namen, die mir mal so über den Weg gelaufen sind.
Welche wurden dir denn so korportiert bisher?
Na ja, das darf ich ja selber nicht sagen.
Ich bin ja nicht so drauf wie du. Es wäre schon schön gewesen, wenn du jetzt so ein...
Na komm, wenn eben meine Blogs sind ein Tanz auf dem Vulkan.
Das ist doch... Es gab auch für mich schon mal Zeitungsartikel,
aber ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, wie ich da genannt wurde.
Ja, so bin ich. Kann man ja googeln.
Kann man vielleicht googeln, ja, weiß ich nicht, irgendwo.
Ich denke, dein Auftritt hier mit den...
Ah, hier hab ich...
Mit den Terravisionen.
Hier hab ich tatsächlich gerade einer. Was bin ich hier? Pionier bin ich.
Pionier, ja.
Pionier und Lichtgestalt. Das wird auch mal... Wir haben doch immer schon mal
überlegt, ob der Titel eigentlich so geil ist.
Lichtgestalt? Jetzt brauchen wir nur noch etwas für das N. Lichtgestalt und
Pionier ist schon mal drin. L, N, P. Was ist... Wofür steht jetzt das N?
Ah, verstehe. Hahaha. Na, wie Rock'n'Roll. So.
Lichtgehalten Pionier.
Ohoho.
Hahaha.
Okay.
Das überlassen wir den Kommentierenden zu dieser Sendung. Ihr werdet euch sicherlich
was lustiges einfallen lassen. Hahaha. Hahaha. Oh man ey.
Pionierpflanze bin ich vielleicht. Alright, Leute, damit sind wir fertig.
Wir lassen euch in den Rest der Woche.
Ich formelle hier wieder mit meinen Pixel rum.
Ja, formel du mal an deinen Pixel rum.
Was du machst, weiß ich nicht. Du machst das Licht aus. Alright,
bis dann Leute. Tschüss.